I have read will that you have this
amazing amount of music that you haven't
released but tracks with extraordinary
artists like Michael Jackson and Prince
and people like that
will you ever release those tracks no
because you know expression artists like
Michael Jackson we're working with
Michael Jackson is his critique and his
two cents so you know without him
guiding on completing it it's not my
right to to do that he was a friend so I
wouldn't I wouldn't do that
I'm also sorry that you brought Michael
Jackson Prince - yes
you brought Michael Jackson and Prince
together he had for one time we had a
show in in Vegas and Michael Jackson
called hey what's Michael okay yeah so I
heard you guys are doing a show tonight
yeah we go on at 9:00 o'clock
Oh rats I got to put the kids to sleep
so I was like well we I'm performing
with Prince later on at 12:00
so anyways Michael came to see me rock
with Prince and it was at a met it was a
magnificent night to see it was me Chris
Tucker and in watching me Chris Tucker
Michael Jackson watching Prince rockland
sage so to make a long story short print
steps off the stage and plays the bass
in Michael Jackson's face rips the
freaking face and ten different pieces
deliver loop make a longer story shorter
Mike Jackson leaves and goes home and
says leave me in the house of breakfast
so I go to his house with breakfast
knock on the door first words he says
when I was Prince playing the bass of my
face is he's no Prince he's just
being nice you know no Prince he's
always been a meanie but bless their
hearts they were so passionate and you
know
I walk over and at this point I write oh
god maybe he won't remember really
humiliated but you know like that close
to my face I'm looking at piggy pops
blue eyes and it takes so much time